the thing I'm asked most frequently is
watching the world is the difference
production designer and an art director
and why is the Oscar called the art
direction Oscar when in point of fact
it's never been given to a so-called art
director for many many many years now
that's the one that I stumble upon the
most think there's some confusion
between the title art director and and
production designer and all those early
pictures I was in art director I'm most
frequently referred to as a set designer
or an art director just because even
within our own Union and within our own
ranks what we do is variously called art
direction or production design depending
on who's speaking well for computer
animation I think people have the idea
and it's a misconception that the
computer does it all and that we're just
sort of pushing buttons or nobody quite
knows the amount of effort that goes
into creating the backgrounds for a
movie I designed the world in which a
film exists and that includes so many
things from greens paint furniture
architecture cars a production design to
me is somebody who builds a narrative
world the production designer leads a
team of set designers character
designers and shader or texture
designers that are working on all the
visual aspects of the film I'd say that
the production designer is the art boss
on the film I describe myself as the
visual storyteller who works with the
director and the writers and
occasionally the producers to to come up
with the concept of what the setting of
the story is I always thought of the job
of solving a puzzle and they hand you a
script that nobody has any clue what it
what it means that there's a lot of you
know people's impressions of what the
script means and you get to really sort
it out and and make it work the
production designer is given or accepts
responsibility for all of the
environments on any given film a great
deal
of a designer's job is to grab the
visual narrative and embedded into the
space to support and to actually tell
its own story ultimately that's what we
really want for for any movie we work on
is for the general audience to not be
able to imagine that it could take place
anywhere else because it's so
appropriate
you